محمد البقالي في هاي نقترب معك اكثر من
المشهد وتطوراته الاجواء التي تترافق او
ترافقت مع اولى جلسات محكمه العدل الدوليه
وما ينتظر غدا
وبعدها هناك احساس عام بان ما يحدث هذا
اليوم هو تاريخي فعلا تاريخي لانه هذه هي
المره الاولى منذ بد هذه الحرب التي تجر
فيها اسرائيل للمحاسبه امام على هيئه
قضائيه دوليه والدوله التي رفعت بها هذه
الدعوه والتي جرتها لهذه المحاسبه لها
رمزيه خاصه هي جنوب افريقيا هي التي عانت
من نظام الابارتايد من نظام الفصل العنصري
على امتداد عقود وبالتالي فهي تاتي باسم
ارثها وباسم نيلسون منديلا بكل ما يمثله
في الضمير العالمي من نضال ضد الفصل
العنصري هذا هو الذي سمعناه من الحقوقيين
هنا من المتخصصين في القانون الدولي ولكن
ايضا من المتظاهرين الذين جاؤوا للتعبير
عن دعمهم لفلسطين خلال هذه المحاكمه وايضا
المظاهره مازالت مستمره لحد هذه اللحظه
بالاضافه الى عدد من الشخصيات التي جاءت
من دول مختلفه من من اوروبا لاعلان دعمها
لدعوى جنوب افريقيا لماذا هذه الدعوه هي
ينظر اليها على انها تاريخيه ولانها مهمه
اولا لانه علاوه على رمزيه الدوله التي
جرت اسرائيل الى المحاكمه بتاريخها في
مواجهه نظام الفصل العنصري ايضا الملف
الذي اعدته جنوب افريقيا وهذه المرافعات
التي سمعناها وناقشنا مع بعض المتخصصين في
القانون الدولي يتحدثون على ان الملف
يصفونه بانه الثقيل على المستوى القانوني
لانه المحكمه هنا لا تنظر
في الى الى الامر الا من وجهه نظر قانونيه
وكل الذين تحدثنا اليهم المتخص مصصين في
القانون الدولي يقولون ان المرافعات قدمت
مستوى عاليا على مستوى الادله القانونيه
التي جوهرها بان اسرائيل تخرق التزاماتها
بما بموجب اتفاقيه منع اباده الجماعيه
الموقعه عام
1948 اعتمدت جنوب افريقيا على ذلك من جهه
على التصريحات الصادره عن المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين الجميع تابع هذه التصريحات
ويبدو ان انها الان وضعت المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين في ورطه عندما توعدوا بتدمير
وحرق غزه او وسموا سكانها ووصفوهم بما لا
بانهم حيوانات وغير ذلك ثم ايضا من خلال
الافعال التي يرتكبها الجيش الاسرائيلي
والتي عددها الفريق القانوني امام المحكمه
وهذه
الافعال جاءت متساو مع هذه التصريحات بما
يعني قانونيا ان نيه الاباده موجوده
ومقصوده وطبعا كان هناك هناك حديث تفصيلي
عما ارتكبته اسرائيل خلال الشهور الثلاثه
الماضيه من قتل وتجويع وحصار وكل ذلك
يندرج ضمن دائره الاباده الجماعيه التي
تعني في التفسير القانوني الاولي انها
محاوله تدمير جزء جزئي او كلي لعنصر او
عرق او شعب والامر هنا يتعلق بفلسطيني غزه
اذا هناك جانب الملف الذي تم تقديمه
والمرافعات والتي كما ذكرنا يقول قانوني
ان مستواها رفيع ثم الجانب الاخر هو فيما
يتعلق ب الدعوه او بما يتعلق بان جنوب
افريقيا الان سبقت الدعاوه التي يمكن ان
تقدمها اسرائيل غدا فيما يتعلق بالدفاع عن
النفس وركزت على مسالتين اولا على ان
الدفاع عن النفس يكون بالتناسب وان ما
يحدث في غزه لا علاقه له لا يحقق هذا
المبدا ثم مساله ان هذا احتلال ومساله
الدفاع عن النفس على مستوى القانون
الدولي لا تعطى للاحتلال هذا الحق لان من
حق الشعوب المحتله ان تقاوم من يحتلها
اسرائيل ايضا في ازمه كبيره لان قرارات
المحكمه هي ملزمه على مستوى الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه ما هي الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه هي ما تطالب به
الان جنوب افريقيا تقول للمحكمه ان
اسرائيل ترتكب جرائم اباده وهذه الادله
التي هي قدمت لكم الان يجب انتم كقضاء
وكمحاولة
[تصفيق]
د الادنى يقضي بتمكين سكان غزه من
المساعدات الغذائيه والطبيه وغير ذلك
وربما يامرون على الاقل بتجنب المدنيين
اسرائيل هي ملزمه قانونيا بالالتزام وبوقف
المعارك لحظتها اذا لم تلتزم من حق
المحكمه ان تدفع بالموضوع الى مجلس الامن
طبعا اسرائيل من المعلوم انها تتمتع بدعم
امريكي
وغربي يمنحها حق الفيتو ولكن على مستوى
الملف وعلى مستوى القضيه برمتها فان حكم
المحكمه سيكون تاريخيا هذا ناهيك على انه
يمكن استعماله امام محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه ابقى معي محمد البقالي انتق